puis j'ai pas que j'ai pas envie de tout
remettre voilà dans l'embarras tout ça
je sais que tu voulais absolument venir
en parler sur le plateau ce soir
mais voilà si tu le sens pas tes nous
c'est là nul au chaud ici on peut
annuler toutes les séquences on préfère
en parler je pense que c'est de ça même
libéré et le fait de faire un témoignage
ce soir je pense protéger les autres
jeunes filles en parler de ce qui m'est
arrivé pour protéger les autres surtout
que j'applique l'avait fait ça des
mineurs donc ça m'a encore plus
traumatisé qu'il fasse à des mineurs moi
je venais tout juste d'avoir 17 ans
quand les faits se sont passés donc
c'est ça tu venais de dieu n'est d'avoir
17 ans ils n'ont pas 18 ans 18 18 ans tu
avais 18 ans c'était en mars 2010 est
ton rêve c'était d'assister à touche pas
à mon poste c'est pour ça qu'on en parle
ce soir parce que voilà ce témoignage
est gelée vu passer voilà sur les
réseaux sociaux un moment j'ai dit oh on
va parler à mélissa christ ont donc
taquin que quesada tu as organisé et
payé le voyage alors qu'il était invité
sur le plateau ils l'ont rappelé la
production même pour passer dans les
coulisses d'ailleurs puisque tu es venu
me voir après t'as vu toute l'équipe
dans les coulisses c'est un plaisir pour
moi voilà de te recevoir
comment tu as commencé à parler avec
christian parce que moi je te dis la
vérité quand je t'ai vu arriver dans la
loge
j'étais persuadé que vous étiez hyper
potes depuis père longtemps donc je me
suis dit bon ben je te reçois avec lui
j'ai passé il était potes je savais pas
que vous connaissiez très peu voilà j'ai
fait des décennies avec toi on a parlé
un petit peu
il m'a raconté un petit peu ces projets
voilà moi et et quand j'ai appris ça
après je me suis limite je m'en suis
voulu parce que je me suis peut-être que
j'aurais dit peut-être plus lui parler
pour savoir que voilà ce qu'elle ait dit
ce qu'elle faisait avec christian tout
ça mais j'ai pas voulu rentrer là-dedans
l'outil bon c'est vrai qu'après avis on
aurait peut-être pu intervenir
alors voila mais voilà et je m'en suis
voulu et donc comment tu as commencé à
parler avec avec son parcours en janvier
parce que tu es fan de télé dont tu le
suivait dans les douches voilà chez lui
félicité m'avait répondu en juin 2009 17
et il m'a dit merci et c'est long
vu que je sais qu'il était invité dans
l'émission avec jean luc reichmann je
lui ai dit que j'étais fan de tpm paix
que c'était mon rêve de venir vous voir
il a dit si tu veux que j'appelle le
producteur et tu viens dès demain il y
aura une place dans le public
et du coup il m'a dit ça il m'a dit je
te paye tout de a à z train hôtel la
nourriture bas au départ c'est
franchement s'ils y perdront renseigner
on se dit c'est sympa de faire ça voilà
on le fait pour des fans d'ouvriers ou
parfois voilà que tu as envie de venir
qui ont pas les moyens de payer ou pas
et est donc la toile un mois une mineure
datant parfois oui bien sûr il faut se
méfier dans tous les cas parce que là
c'était lui c'était pas la production
qui allait payer
c'est ça mais bon après on verra pour
les filles oui c'est sûr lui mélissa
après moi je te dis moi je suis moi
franchement je comprend elle s'est dit
voilà il m'invite je suis à la
production des ppp qu'est ce qui va
m'arriver c'est particulièrement tout à
fait et je comprends que lui je suis
très content que tu sois venu alors on a
vu qu'il a envoyé des photos intimes a
beaucoup de jeunes filles est ce que ça
a été aussi le cas pour toi ou pas du
tout ça m'a traumatisé du coup j'ai tout
supprimer c'était avant ou après ton
d'état venus danser avant avant d'accord
avait envoyé une photo de ces gens m'ont
vu avec une photo nue